[Music]
[Music]
good morning
everyone
happy saturday
we've made it we've made it this far
we have worked on our renders every
single weekend
this marks the fourth weekend
um man i am beat i am tired
i'm sure a lot of you are as well um you
all have been working very very hard on
your art and we're gonna wrap it up
today on stream
so
i'm going to be
processing my
art and color correcting my art in da
vinci studio today it's gonna be a very
chill stream i'm tired i was up late
last night working on the render
um so we're just gonna be hanging out
having a good time and chilling together
um for those of you who don't know
we've been doing a 3d challenge over the
last month it's called moving
meditations
and
i've challenged all of you to take a
prompt pick your favorite animation and
create something cool from it uh the
deadline is tomorrow tomorrow night at
11 59 pm pst
uh there's a submission link in the
description so you can check that out if
you are wrapping up your art just like
myself pushing it to the final day
um but i want to go over
my process here in davinci studio with
all the renders
um
you know anytime
i wrap up a render this is my process um
it's how i color grade my stuff it's how
i add certain effects like vignettes and
film grain and lens
distortion and whatnot
so i think it's a very important process
i think it's something that can take
your render to the final stages and it's
not truly done until in my at least for
me until it passes through
um
a spice pass as i like to call it
um so
let's just let's just hop in
i got my tea here
be hanging out with y'all
if you want to join me
uh da vinci is actually free davinci
resolve is free there's a link in the
description if you go to the blackmagic
uh they're one of the sponsors too you
know if you win
um
the
top
five
for the movie meditation challenge
you'll get da vinci resolve studio
licenses perpetual licenses
so just go down there in the description
click that link you can download davinci
studio or davinci resolve for free um
it's like 95
of the actual paid version
um so you'll be able to follow along
pretty much the entire stream if you
guys would like
but let's get into it let's get into it
all right
davinci so
my render let me let me just play my
render for you a couple times
um
this is kind of what i'm working with
i will probably do one more render
tonight
overnight
there's a couple things i'd like to
tweak
namely the animation here on the screen
but there's gonna be text and titles on
screen here kind of talking about the
challenge
what we've done in the challenge etc
a little calibration loading on the
monitor
built this vr space
this like virtual volume that actually
lights the character which is pretty
sweet
and then
it will transition
into the first piece of art and i just
pulled one of the submissions
so far i'll have to cut the top 100 to
figure out what the first render would
be in order for me to actually finalize
my render so i know i'm gonna have to do
some re-rendering at a certain point
so
let's go through
let's color correct this let's add some
effects let's spice it up
and that shouldn't take too long
once that's done i will probably head
back into unreal and be adding a little
bit more details and kind of wrapping it
up that way the stream will be fairly
quick
um
you know there's not too much to do
because most of it's pretty much done at
this point
but before we hop in
usually at this point there'd be some
sort of
you know sponsor segment no sponsor
today
but we do have
some kit bash codes the final round
of kit bash codes for y'all um
so
this is
the last 50 codes right for those of you
all who want to check out the kit bash
stuff i you know used it in my render
it's all these buildings in the
background here
all of these guys
are
a bunch of different buildings bunch of
different kid bash buildings and they do
a bunch of
themed kits i'm sure you all have heard
of them at this point but
the link or not the link
the code is in the description it is
amped 50. amped 50
it's you 50 off any kit bash kit you
want the first 50 people
to use that code
get 50 off
good times they're also one of the
sponsors for this challenge and are
giving away a free kit to
every single top 100 artist
which is amazing it's our first top 100
prize
and you know as you win
uh the top five you get your choice of
two more so you get a total of three
from kip bash they're really
really holding it down for this
challenge so thank you to kit bash um go
get yourself some kits 50 off i believe
it's 50 off your uh your cart
as opposed to just one kit
get them while they last
all right so render wise from unreal
engine right there's some flickering in
here i think this will just happen
uh this is happening from like
the amount of samples here in my
raytraced reflections so i would need to
up that i rendered this at 32 i would
need to up it to 64. i think if i up the
resolution to it'll help with that as
well
but i had to get something out for the
stream today
so i'm hitting p in davinci to go uh
between full screen here
and i am in i believe this is the edit
tab yep this is the edit tab and it
works really cool there's a bunch of
different tabs here at the bottom
um that you can go through
so we'll be uh mainly in color today
right so if i were to get rid of this
node
and by the way it is a node-based system
it's super cool you have all your
all your wheels on the left your gamma
uh gain
right lift all that good stuff and we
can see our histogram on the right side
where all of our data is we got darks on
the on the outskirts and on the center
it's very bright as you can kind of tell
it's a visual representation of our
levels here
um and then we have like a little curves
adjustment
that we can mess with and stuff we can
mess with uh different um
you know
different hues and the highlights maybe
we want to shift it
in the shadows you know we can mess with
lens distortion we can mess with uh with
bloom we can mess with chromatic
aberration we could do film green we're
gonna do all that stuff we're gonna do
vignetting et cetera et cetera um we
have temperature here on the left you
can mess with with that if you want to
cool things off or warm it up a bit
tint right is obviously uh well not
obviously for those of you who have
never done this before we have magenta
we can tint it towards magenta or we can
go green with it
and i kind of like
um that like
matrixy green color so i'm gonna work in
a little bit of that as we work if you
double click any of these it'll reset it
to zero
we have contrast of course
and there's all there's a bunch of
different ways you can do stuff here in
in davinci just like there's a million
ways to do
pretty much anything in any software so
we can add contrast this way
right double click to reset or we can
crank the gain a little bit
drop the shadows
right to get a nice image like this
is another way
to add contrast
we can use
our
curves adjustment here to add contrast
lots of different ways to do this
so we're going to start from scratch
though this is the image i exported
from
unreal engine last night and i set this
up kind of specifically i'm using asus
for the most control here
and
it is my first time using aces from
unreal engine
in da vinci studio
and i'm not gonna lie
i'm not gonna lie at all i followed our
man william foshea he's got a great
tutorial on how to do it so i set that
up via his tutorial last night i've
linked it in the description
for those of you curious on how to do
that process basically you set up a
like an open color i o profile inside of
unreal engine and that will export out
you know specific settings you gotta do
a couple things here in your movie
render queue to get it to export in a
certain way we're doing exrs this is an
exr sequence as you can tell by
the title down here
um and we've set up
davinci in a specific way
if we go to little cog on the bottom
right you can go to the color management
tab and we can set our color science to
asus cct
i'm using aces 1.2 and our output
transform is rec709 all this stuff is
covered in the william poche video but
that is a very quick
little snippet of
what you need to do to set up davinci to
work with aces here
all right
let's take a moment
to just say what's up in the chat how
are you guys doing
what's going on
uh drunken whaler is da vinci working in
4k resolution monitor i'm about ui
because i have some issues with the 4k
it's looking upscale i
can't find a solution for this
um
yes this is a 4k resolution monitor that
i'm on right now um
it absolutely works in one yeah
uh visual what's up what up visual
urban dust i should add some blinking
lights well i think actually oh i didn't
include it in this one but
the screen itself uh has a little bit of
flicker to it
oh man it has been it has been a month
trying to get this render done y'all it
has been crazy i feel the burn i'm ready
for
a little break i'm going to get this top
100 montage now we're going to judge it
of course
next week live judging be there for it
it's going to be crazy
we're going to go over the top 100 and
after that
i go to
uh let's see i go to detroit
no i go to chicago i'm going to chicago
for half res so if you're there for half
res i'll see you there um and then i'll
be at camp mograph the next week so i'm
gonna be going on a little
a little mograph
3d vacation
by going to 3d events
it's going to be great i cannot wait
it's gonna be so good
agent r you need to fix your sleeping
schedule yes you do sleep is the most
important thing i didn't get much of it
last night unfortunately always try and
get the most sleep you can
um
yeah
sleep
very important
uh it's good to see you all in chat
though
heck
all right for those of you who actually
uh use da vinci let me see a little
thumbs up
it is free by the way so
it is it's kind of a no-brainer if
you're trying to edit anything
it is the way to go
all right
let's color this thing
do it so in the color tab
right this is node based right so we're
going to hit alt s to make a new node
all s will get you a new node every
single time
so no matter what we do
we can always switch things up nothing's
ever baked in which is fantastic now
this is looking a little
flat
so i want to bring some contrast to this
i also want to add a
vignette to this
um there's a lot of things i want to do
to this i want to add some color to this
let's see
yeah
so if i just
crank the contrast slider you can see on
the right side the histogram just kind
of opens up but we are clipping our
whites and we are clipping our blacks
and you can really you can visually see
that with the histogram so
it's a great
great tool to have
if you are in parade mode you might be
seeing this but i'm in waveform here
um we also have histogram we got
vectorscopes this helps for
pulling the color in a certain direction
so we can kind of see that it's pointed
towards greenish between yellow and red
so that's a great visual representation
of
of that
but if we shift things green let's just
say we go really green you can kind of
see the colors separate
in that waveform viewer there which is
cool
green is up top
but all right let's get serious here
let's dive in let's get a nice look
so
i know i want it to be darker
on the outsides
but not too bright in the middle
let's bring our gamma up i want to fill
a bit more
of the color space everything's crunched
down low like this
so i want to bring it up
this is looking a bit more normal and
vibrant
just a nice subtle curve here
nothing too intense
generally this is feeling
pretty nice
all right the next thing i mean i'm a
sucker for vignetting so
i'm going to go ahead and i'll right
click this and we're going to
label this node we'll call this contrast
and if you hit alt s we can make a new
node
i'm going to call this one
[Music]
vignette
vignette
that vignette let's get it
alright so if we go to
the mask tab here
and we select the circle mask
we can open this thing up
all right we'll get this blue box just
generally situated and if we open up
this right side we can
really feather this thing out
open this up nice
like this is our vignette
and we can again do this a number of
different ways we can bring the gamma
down but you'll notice it's all
happening from the center so
we want to
invert that all right so we're gonna hit
this little box right here it's gonna
invert that selection you can see it
right up in here
and if you hit the little magic wand you
can see just that layer you can solo
that layer and see what's going on
uh gray is transparent which means we
have these borders here that we want to
bring down right so we can do that with
the gamma probably not the way to do it
we can do it with the lift
that's a little crunchy
let's go back to
our graph here i think what needs to
happen
is we actually just need to adjust the
mask itself
ctrl d
is going to hide that layer
kind of see what we're doing
i want to dip it down a little bit
so i like to go extreme with things
first and then kind of dial it back so
obviously this is really intense
we're going gonna open this up
and this is your feather right here
all right nice something like that we
can go back to
this guy and just kind of
work that in we can also do the lift too
yeah
but that crunches it a little too much
maybe a little something like that
all right before and after a little
subtle vignetting here
very nice so we can do uh let's see
let's select our contrast we'll add one
in between
we'll call this color
let's see if we can't mess with a little
bit of this color here um
again lots of different ways we can do
this you know we can warm it up i like
that that matrixy green
and it kind of is already in that
direction right if we go to the vector
scope we can kind of see that
things are being pushed in between
yellow and red
and there's some sign there's a cyan
blast somewhere in here
we could also crank the saturation too
because i am colorblind
this kind of helps me visualize a little
bit more of what's going on obviously
this is way too intense
but we got some pinks magentas oranges
in the skyline
definitely green inside there's some
warmth as well
i also like to just mess
with a bunch of these values here
i know one of these crunches and like
adds a bunch of texture i'm not a fan of
that though
one way too if you are like out of ideas
you can use their built-in luts too
right so you can kind of go through
these and see what it would look like
with a lut on it
um let's see
let's go ahead and disable these ctrl d
and maybe we'll add one because we we
technically need one
in order to add a lut to it
wow these are all really
really crunchy
those first lots are converters so like
to convert from logarithmic to linear or
from one gamma to another
yeah when you're looking for the left
maybe you can choose different ones
instead of vfx io or scroll down i'm not
sure
yeah there's a lot of different options
here we got sony
that's super intense my goodness
red camera
wow
that's awesome though i think it's under
the film looks them
those are the ones you're probably
looking for
that looks great too olympus
oh i'm just browsing in general
let's see
yeah these look great
that looks awesome
beautiful there's custom here
this was my alternate realities one
which looks wacky on anything other than
my alternate realities render
film looks is pretty nice very very
contrasty very dark
um
there's probably like a nice little like
shift here in the color tones
this one's not bad
so what we can do is we can double click
that and it will be applied to this node
and we can bring our other nodes back
it's going to look way too intense with
what we currently have
but what you can do is you can probably
let's see if we can start with this and
end with
this get this out of here
it's just too much though so what you
can do
is let's see which tab is it
yeah there we go it's this tab right
here so this will choose kind of like
the opacity
of the node right so if we just want a
little bit of that
look we can kind of dial it in that way
and of course double click to to undo
so that's a that's not a bad one um
let's go
our
setup and it looks like they're dropping
like the mid-tones or something so
we can try something similar
i do like that darkness though it feels
great
it's really focused on the center of
this
of this scene
as far as color goes
you know i think it's just a matter of
playing with it
so we have our shadows mid-tones and
highlights i'm using this little uh
toggle on the right side here this is
our our log wheels
and really isolate the mid-tones here
the highlights
and the shadows
wow that's crazy it's all over the place
yikes
so we can dip the shadows down towards
green
and we can bring the highlights maybe up
towards like a
magenta or something
or we can do that classic like warm cool
situation let's see if we do shadows
maybe towards like a bluish
and the highlights go towards maybe a
more of a warmish tone
we can really exaggerate it too just to
kind of see what's going on
and then we can dial it back of course
being colorblind definitely doesn't help
i'll tell you that much
it's not a bad look though it looks
pretty cool
so we can add
some
bloom i think that would actually really
help this
uh make it feel a little bit more
natural
so we can open up the effects tab here
one thing that like
kind of confused me at first with
davinci was you can't really move
windows around like you can in
you know a bunch of other programs you
can't undock and dock certain things
there are certain things you can dock
and undock in davinci but like
i can't just like start moving this
around all crazy and like put the scopes
up here the curves down here this viewer
on this monitor this over here it has a
way of doing that a little bit um
but it's nice in the way that everything
is kind of like docked and undocked here
so you can really clean up your
workspace
quite easily by toggling all these
different options
and i'm a fan of that
it takes a little getting used to but
i prefer it in the long run
all right so let's search
for
bloom
glow yes it is glow
chromatic glow uni oh so okay we got the
the red giant effects i believe
i've never messed with these let's just
see what happens
um
all right let's hide this
type this in
my god
all right obviously way too much so the
threshold amount
only a certain amount of things can
can get the glow
um and it's getting this like ridiculous
contrast
on the things that are glowing
so we can bring uh let's see aberration
i don't want any of that right now
color
bring the saturation down
looks a little bit better um we can
bring it up maybe just a touch
let's see what color strength does
weird okay so it actually like removes
it in a way
it's making it super red it's crazy
it's just a little bit of saturation
um
the size okay let's go up on the size
just a bit
and then the intensity
will bring down and then we'll just walk
this up very slowly so in davinci if you
actually use the slider
it moves a bit faster but if you just
hover over the numbers itself you can
get a real fine tune on it
all right let's get that back down and
slowly bring it up
critical exception
i've never seen this ever in my life
i'll save i'll save the project i will
save and continue
wow did it just crash but like
i think it just crashed but it just kept
barreling through
brute force
geez
dang i'm trying to figure out what is
the
oh shoot
the middle mouse
hmm okay
it does not like me doing that
i forget how
to pan with
the pen tablet but it is
it is okay
oh another thing um i'm all about
getting sidetracked so if you go to the
edit tab
and i'm there there might be a way to do
this
uh in the color tab we can search for it
but
lens correction
right we can undo this i added some
and this is in the inspector tab
in the edit panel
and each clip comes with a bunch of
things you can do with it so of course
basic stuff like zoom
right we can move stuff around we can
rotate it of course we can do
pitch and yaw and all that good stuff uh
quick reset there we can flip it um
let's see of course we can crop it here
it's all built in
we can stabilize it if we want but the
lens correction
is a good way
to do this to your footage
or the opposite
right i just want to give it a little
bit
a little bit
of that bend
right there
very nice
making our footage worse
so that it looks better
all right back in the color tab let's
get this
glow down
[Music]
we can also figure out what point we we
do the vignette i feel like the vignette
should always be last
i think
glow i believe should go after the v-net
because
what happens is the lens lets less light
hit the sensor around the edges so it
will naturally glow less there
you know what that's very fair that is
very fair i'm trying to get rid of
this clipping that we're seeing in the
darks here and i think that's just
me needing to take that contrast it is
the contrast right there's so much
data that we see back here that we're
losing with our contrast so
i think i just need to get a little bit
better with this here hop back in
and see what we can do
oh interesting
all right
all right so if you right click these
you can remove them
we just add some contrast oh yeah okay
so
those black levels
they really get clipped pretty quickly
there
um
let's see our vignette
he's probably doing a little bit of that
color is definitely not
tied to glow for a second i'm using ctrl
d to hide all this stuff
so what we can do is actually
bring up
this value here on the tail end and just
to give you an extreme example of what
that looks like you've seen you know
you've seen this look
on instagram this photo look where it
fades out the darks
right and i think a little bit of that
is nice
personal preference
and kind of just bring that up a little
bit
i don't like what it's doing to the
outside there so you gotta be real
real close with it
and we go back to our
waveform here to see what's going on
offset will just generally move the
entire waveform
so maybe a little bit of offset could
help us out
just to brighten things up a little bit
and then the vignette
can come in
let's see if we can set this to like
certain blending mode i don't know how
to do that quite
at this point
but that's okay
there we go that feels a little bit
better yeah we're not losing
detail at this point
and we can try
see if we solo this
we can try and remove the highlights
at least from the windows here
so this little tab here this is the
qualifier
and we can select
that point there
and now it looks like we have control
over just that area
so it's going to brighten up just those
specific spots it kind of got rid of our
vignette effect which is not what we
want
um we want to remove that from the
vignette so i'm trying to think like
is it a reverse situation where we
invert that selection
okay so that's doing it just on that
spot
i think that's what i want there
yeah
exactly what i want
great you see that how it's
oh no but that's not what i want because
i um
oh wait i think i need to undo
the
instead
that's what i want
yeah so you see what brings everything
down except for those windows
yeah that's great
that's great
okay
um
let's clean up
that qualification though so if we go
and we click this little
magic wand tool
we can kind of just feather that off a
little bit
because it's looking a little chunky um
we could do it from
saturation
luminance only this is kind of
everything working together
not a bad look let's see
if we just kind of
we just want the sky
you want to save that sky
i don't mind bringing the buildings down
as that will actually help
pop the buildings out from that
background
all right that's nice
and then we can kind of
drag this little left side here
to feather it out
a little bit of feather goes a long way
a little something like that
but i want to get rid of
all this other stuff
so
if we hit the minus dropper
and we minus those guys
it's going to get it's going to get rid
of that
so that just gets rid of everything it's
very similar
similar tone here
we can just work it in nice and slowly
nice and subtly and try and find a nice
balance here
messing with the q
that's not bad
let's find that nice balance there
cool and then saturation
if there's a slight roll off on
everything
you'll be better off than just hard
edges
all right
so now when we bring this down
i see it's flipping that i kind of want
the whole thing then huh
let's go extreme with it
let's go back to the qualifiers
and see if we can't
maybe it doesn't really matter if we
have
a bit more of
those lights
keeping the highlights in it's not a bad
idea
let's see what that looks like
oh it definitely muddies it up
in the rafters
and it's taking the stars down too
that's a tricky one
i wonder if there's a way to just
set it to
scream
i mean that would be the easiest way
and i also realize i'm going really
intense with it so maybe it doesn't need
to be
that crazy
something like that
and we'll just focus that scene right
here in the center
that feels pretty nice
oh a nice little glow going there feels
good
maybe adjust this a touch the threshold
amount
so it gets a little bit of the stage but
not too much because
we don't want to lose it right if we go
in
ah so now that vignette
needs to be animated right
so we can keep the vignette
probably up until
here
and then it needs to start moving and
growing so
let's see
[Music]
let's take that vignette
um we have our key frames here on the
right side
i'm not sure
specifically where to set this keyframe
but
now we have three correctors i wonder
what that's probably the stuff on the
left here effects perhaps
our glow
sizing
all right we want to
key frame
this mask here
one way to find out is to just put a
keyframe on everything
move forward
adjust it
and figure out where it is so
corrector three
circular
window okay so that's what we actually
need to adjust
that's good to know we can undo all
those keyframes we made
and we'll move forward to the point
where we feel like
boom let's say right there
and we'll drop down corrector three
circular window make that keyframe
did it make the keyframe there
not cn1
maybe corrector three neat no just a
circular window i guess
we'll move forward
until we kind of
get to the edges here
we'll move this out
and we'll open it up a touch
all right so why it didn't make
huh strange okay so here's what i'll do
let's go back to the point where we want
to start it right here
all right circular window has a keyframe
i guess that means it's looking for
changes all right i'll make a small
change boom there it is let's set the
keyframe that way
come to the edge
open that up
boom
wonderful
so that'll scale up with us as we zoom
in here
or dolly it's a dolly zoom technically
samuel
what's up
thank you for that super chat man
very kind of you
uh this has been a blast you've learned
so much in blender you do have an idea
uh for a prompt the camera orbits around
a fixed sphere every everyone uh
everything else is up to creativity
uh i think it could make some
interesting renders oh okay
so like everyone is kind of like
it could be a miniature scene everyone's
gazing at this giant you know maybe
everyone's looking at a planet or
something
that's not a bad idea it's a slow orbit
full 360 you'll lose your mind that top
100 montage is
i mean you will fall
down
from dizziness
after the first minute probably so you
got to keep it nice and subtle
man i had to hand animate this darn
character
ugh
not fun
not fun we can adjust the glow here too
so it kind of like
creeps in a little bit more to this guy
sweet
that's pretty awesome
so how um you're asking how this
material was made
so
here's what i did um i was doing his
chest texture looked good
um the character is from daz free
program
technically all of this is free which is
nuts
i used unreal engine to make the scene i
use daz to make the character
um and i'm using davinci to
color correct and process all of these
programs are free which is mind-blowing
um
in terms of the animated screen what i'm
doing is actually
creating all right so this is kind of
it's a little involved here but what i'm
doing is uh
i know that i originally built this with
this like um this tv grid pattern right
so it's nine by four
and the top and bottom is one by one um
it's nine by nine screens
so what i did was i went in after
effects i made a composition that was
nine by four i scaled it up so it's like
2700 by 1200
and
i took that i threw a grid on it so i
was looking at all these tv screens in
theory right
and
built out different uh graphics to be
displayed on those screens
and i even went as far as like so if you
notice here
we have all of these we have this render
i guess we'll start here
we have this like loading calibrating
kind of step here where all of these
things flash on
so i had to go in and
add all these numbers here
to count the screen and they do like the
rgb cmyk
situation
black and white on top and
and each one of those was kind of
it's half hand done and half
trying to find ways to make it faster in
after effects
um
and then as far as like this loading bar
is you know very basic after effects
stuff
projected these are all in their own
compositions so whatever's in one
composition is
copied across all these different
squares
and then when we get to this
point the renders actually it
transitions to
the first render of the challenge
and i had to like
hand animate all these will hand animate
that's saying a lot
i had to show and hide a bunch of white
squares
to reveal
the render and you can actually see it
react on the character too the lighting
on the character
and that is with a bunch of emissives
emissive texture objects in
unreal engine so i saved out all each
one of these screens as its own video so
i had what uh five different videos
and i brought them into unreal engine
and i used the what is it the media
player he's the media player um it's
actually the same process for that music
video i did in unreal engine a while
back with that video screen emitting a
video
um
it's just a little bit cleaner this time
around with unreal engine 5
and
you know after having using unreal
engine for a while
a little bit easier
can you guys spot
any easter eggs here
there's a few
there's a few
all right so let's see if we can't
animate the glow
because technically there is an exposure
shift happening here that you can
actually see if i scrub it pretty
quickly
so we need to adjust our glow a little
bit i'll start from
here
grab that glow um
we'll drop down the effects you need
glow
boom
why can't i not make a keyframe on that
yeah it looks like it's just the effect
tab
all right
we'll get that threshold a little bit
oh let's see if that works yeah okay
hey there we go all right then we'll
come forward
and we'll get that threshold up just or
down i guess just a bit
[Music]
just a little yeah
that's good
[Music]
sweet
awesome
what else shoot what else
let's see let's just scroll through
these effects we got blurs
we got some color stuff
we can generate some stuff we can key
some stuff out
light all right
lens reflections all right let's see
what this does let's just have some fun
here let's see what lens reflections
does
um where are you
lens flare
oh we got to be careful with that
aperture diffraction okay that's like
the leveled up
glow
um
see what halation does
light rays i'm not even going to mess
with that
all right we have the refined features
beauty features
so some of these effects are only in the
studio version
oh let's see
noise reduction okay
chromatic aberration removal
sharpen we can stylize it
there's a vignette option interesting
i wonder i wonder let's let's just
mess with that
watercolor okay
interesting
um
wow we can add motion blur we can make
it stop motion
we can add motion trip wow this is
awesome
analog damage
film damage film grain
yes please film green
let's do a little bit of that
detail recovery dang
a bunch of warp effects ooh lens
distortion let's see if this lens
distortion is better than just like the
built-in one
fisheye fixer
camera shake
lots of cool stuff here
these are all the uh
and there's like three companies in one
that uh
red giant
universe
plug-ins i guess that's what they're
called um we have some glow generators
all right we have a lot of stuff to play
with
sweet
hmm what are we gonna do first
what do we want to do first
let's see about this vignette
goodness okay
yeah i don't know about this
advanced
goodness
okay well first off
oh
god i feel like i'm passing out here
jeez no joke okay no joke
um i did this like stunt plane thing
in vegas and they take you up and they
like fly around
and then and basically
i don't know if they try to make it past
we were filming a thing all right
and so they went hard and my vision no
joke just went like this
and then it got to the point where i
couldn't see anything
my eyes were open but i couldn't see
and i was like i guess this is what it's
like to pass out
it's not so bad
yeah so that was pretty sweet um
anamorphosize
[Music]
all right so that's what no
effect you hit ctrl d to hide it yeah
okay that's no effect
it's doing some similar work i mean so
you set it to uh
let's see
if we bring this let's make it really
intense just so we know what it's doing
i'm always down for that
so full
intensity and we set it to add
that won't do it
that's taking away
the multiply really
if you change the color from from black
to like a dark blue or something then
you'll see the difference more
it's going to make it dark blue though
right
report
um
there's got to be an effect in here
somewhere
that's going to allow the highlights to
shine
okay overlay
i knew you were in here somewhere
let's see
let us bring these eyes
back up
you're also gonna have to animate the
size instead of mask
i wonder if that's better than
these
i do one at the same time huh okay yep
all right so that is that one this one
is ours i kind of like ours better
yeah all right but it's good to know
it's there
certainly
um
what is next we want to mess with next
watercolor let's just see
what watercolor does
oh
my god
looks like some ai art okay
um no offense to any of those robots out
there
let's see um
rgb
yes smoothness how smooth
oh perfect
beautiful
oh that's so weird
oh my goodness
we want
we want just a little bit of that
chunk
but do we
that's
interesting
i wish it wouldn't
brighten our image like that
because i'd be pretty cool with these
lines
anyway
that's cool i never mess with that
um film green i know that's happening
that's gonna be the last effect
i know that
and it's probably gonna be hard to see
here
um let's make ourselves a little bit of
space here
boom boom boom
so film grain
um
let's try 35 millimeter
400 let's go uh
200
why
it lets me do it
like on other things
weird
yeah this is a very um
very subtle effect here that you
probably really won't be able to tell
but a little bit of this goes a long way
i'm all for this just a little bit
that's cool
you can solo just the grain
[Music]
grain size texture
[Music]
that's awesome
beautiful
all right so i know that's last um let's
see what hellation does
i'll turn off the grain just for now
ctrl d
hmm
[Music]
it feels like some glow
wow that's advanced their secondary glow
geez
so halation is in film when they do in
color the red channel is like below so
sometimes that light enters the sensor
then bounces back and exposes the red
channel again so it's like a glowy
effect on the red channel where there's
like high contrast
interesting
and then the secondary is the green
channel
and it's usually less strong so it gets
like a yellowy
glow and then a redder wider though
sometimes it should be really subtle
it's like some chromatic aberration
level like it's got to be
super subtle
um lens reflections lens distortion i
want to see what this lens distortion is
all about i guess technically it would
come first
and let's hide let's go back to the edit
tab let's hide this lens correction here
because we're definitely getting it
once we don't get it twice
oh wow okay so i can replicate the
border
tile it
reflect it or just be black okay so we
would have to scale up our image a
little bit
yes it's definitely more accurate than
uh
the one that we just did
because it's not really affecting the
center it's more affecting the edges
and i did have this going in
unreal but i noticed some slight
like stepping that was occurring
so i was like i'm just doing da vinci
and then if you adjust the channels oh
wow when i told you i could totally
cover everything up i'll leave quick so
if you adjust the different channels
you'll get accurate chromatic aberration
more in the edges and all of that stuff
that's cool
i am not a fan of them chrome
abs
is this overdone far too much
bubble blend how does that work yeah
um let us
scale what
we can't even scale
i have to nest it
right click
uh new compound clip
yeah whatever and we will scale it up
maybe a little intense i don't know
um
oh that's right because i nested it
we gotta go in right click open in
timeline and then we can
work on this
maybe just bring it back a little bit
that's not bad
it feels a little bit better
oh i have color hidden one up color
hidden
glow on the color
whereas color just making
i'm confused
all right there's no glow on the color i
think it's just the
way this is uh
doing a thing here so we can take
let's see let's go back to that keyframe
let's make the adjustment here first
like 91 or something
[Music]
[Music]
so now we're talking about glow let's
actually see what
this aperture diffraction does
wow okay
do you actually have some stars up in
here too
oh quality absolutely final composite
yes
all right
and smooth it out
very cool
wow
all right i reshaped let's see if this
changes yeah it just adds a couple more
dealies
whoa
that's cool
this is a tough one you know like you
can easily go to town here on these
effects and just be like oh this looks
cool this is cool but like
you you gotta find specific reference
for this stuff
and that's the tough thing
is gathering that reference i'm sure is
a little bit more difficult than just
like uh you know your basic
reference situation
but i'm just going down the line here
i've never messed with these effects
before
i think i just don't like the fact that
it's red
good good
my eyes yo i've seen sunshine that
movie's great
when he's just like staring at the sun
one percent
colorize all right that's what i want
[Music]
i don't even know what this would be
like
[Music]
somewhere i don't know i don't even know
i'm just guessing at this point
art direction okay
[Music]
i'm down for a little bit of that though
it feels pretty sweet i wonder if glow
and this combined
would be
too much but there's only one way to
find out
[Music]
it's pretty sweet though
all right lens reflections what's going
on here
wow so many options
oh
[Music]
this is getting into
the territory that i think is a little
much
but you know i've added them i've had
them in the past
jeez
this is fun though
going through all this stuff
it's one of those things where you just
like
good god
subtlety is key subtlety is key
man i don't know
what is this even based off like how
what is the reference on this
um
shining a flashlight
from the side into your
dslr into your phone
you're gonna see some of this stuff
so i think that's what we're trying to
get at here but like
dude this is a
this is a lot
lens coating
wow
that's advanced
reflect elements two
reflect elements three reflect elements
four
yes so this needs to like
[Music]
one i say one percent
oh god 0.01
and i said eve do you even notice the
difference
barely there's just like a slight color
shift
in the image
and not a good one
either
so man there's a lot of stuff to mess
with here
in davinci
um
let me get rid of that
let's render our clip real quick so it's
playing a little slower because of what
we're putting it through
so what you can do
is if you right click it and you click
render cache color output
it's going to do a thing it's going to
render it
but i feel like it's not going to render
it until you tell it to and you actually
need to go to
let's see playback render cache set that
to user and it'll just automatically go
you saw that red bar stretch across
it's going to do its thing it's going to
turn blue
ryan my render was crashing all last
night no worries brother it happens
you know you gotta tweak it walk it back
do what you can
hypoxo okay okay
where's the penguin all right the
penguin
penguin is is out penguin's out for sure
um
let's see
enhance
might be a little penguin there
might be a little
penguin
pegan on the side
gotta add me a penguin to every render
at this point
it's been so much fun doing like cable
sims and stuff in c4d
it's so satisfying to just have it work
have it work in real time
that's how i got these guys here on the
side
these nice cables here just a quick sim
c4d
and then knocked them around with some
cylinders
as colliders it totally worked these
other ones are hand placed though
like these guys up front here
these these wires here
we're just messing with some splines and
stuff i probably could have done it
as a sim
now that i think about it i could have
just like
pushed them with a box
to straighten them out here
and or at least pinned them here at
these points i could do that
but yeah i'm feeling pretty good with
this
it is still rendering
i think the only thing i'm going to do
here is just kind of maybe make this
screen a little bit more advanced
give it a little bit more motion here in
the beginning
to have those reflections play with the
floor would be really nice
but i finally figured out the glass
i figured out how to do
um good surface imperfections in unreal
um
and i'll probably hop into unreal
pretty soon here
[Applause]
to keep tweaking
q c cuber
what is up welcome to the stream
let me let me play it for you
we got the final video
chunking along here
very curious as to why it is doing that
it is rendered but i you know i'm
throwing a bunch of stuff at it too so
[Music]
it's a little bright
huh it's a little bright
i'm gonna wait on it though because i'm
gonna be changing that screen anyway
over the next day
it was funny i had this character in a
normal looking chair
but
because his pants were so big
he was blocking the chair completely so
look i was just sitting down
and floating sitting on nothing
i'm like i can't have that i got to give
them something
so i added that bench
these little cable sims 2
and c4d behind them there
[Music]
looking real nice
all right
i can't really think of anything else
here in uh
in davinci like that that's mainly what
i do i color correct i had film grain i
had some lens effects
that's pretty much it you know i can
keep tweaking to the end of time
absolutely
let me walk you through some of the cool
stuff that i did in unreal engine
and maybe we'll tweak a little bit more
before we close it out
uh viggo what did i use for the
character i used dabs
i used dabs as a free program actually i
didn't know it was free
okay
let's open up
unreal engine
[Music]
and while unreal opens
i'll play you all a little tune
so we got to get we got to get the
reverb on here at some point you were
like oh let's get it set up today i'm
like i probably won't play
uh
here i am playing this thing
uh
we gotta get the reverb going it's just
gonna sound so much better for sure for
sure
mm-hmm
[Music]
that's the native flute
that one you know if you can blow into a
coke bottle honestly that's harder than
playing the native flute this thing's
pretty sweet it's from a blue bear
flutes
all hand made
really really nice
from american cedar i believe now this
i'm only going to put you through this
torture
for 30 seconds and then we're gonna get
back to the art
uh but this is called an uh a nay
it's an arabic nay
and it's uh i think one of the oldest
instruments ever
i i've heard as young as 2 000
years and as old as 4 000
and it's a dried reed
and it's made by
i'm not even going to try to pronounce
his name correctly
but if you look up arab instruments
um and you dig in you know you can find
out i got this from arab instruments
it's made by this guy
there he is
um takes two years to dry and then
you know they drill the right holes and
they tune it and all this
but this thing is
darn
difficult to play holy crap like i said
i'm going to put you through this for
like 20 seconds
[Music]
there's nothing worse than bad flute
[Applause]
and it jumps octaves on me
because you really got to lock down that
those octaves you can hit like three to
four octaves on this thing it's super
cool it's all based on how your mouth
hits this thing
god it's so difficult it takes like five
minutes for me to
start getting something that sounds good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's about all the torch i'll put you
guys through
this time
back to unreal engine
that's why you all are here
in the first place
all right
maybe when we get the reverb set up
it'll sound a little bit better
okay
let's figure out uh why we're flickering
so intensely let's go to our
post-process volume let's just kind of
get a hold on things here
uh let's search for ray tracing
let's turn off these bounces
you know it's because i have uh
let me get my sequencer back
really quick uh
i'm not in a camera of any sort am i
whoa
lots going on here lots going on it's
because of this flicker i believe oh no
you know why
doing this i believe is because
ctrl shift
ctrl shift g
let's let's uh
oh shoot okay
i think it's just
the amount of reflective objects i have
in the scene is
a little much
for my computer at this moment in time
let's get that back is the inner room
that i'm looking for
why won't it let me
that's annoying
let's take this quality down let's go to
high
oh okay
we can breathe just a little bit
i'll walk you through some of the stuff
i was doing here
let me just get this room back
come on now
where are you at
gotta be in here somewhere
dude son here we go is this it room
light
that's the room light all right
materialize for it fluorescent housing
here we go in a room bam
all right
so i think the biggest thing that's like
chunking this whole thing up is uh these
video materials
i'm
running these image sequences these
large
image sequences
that's probably what's doing it and i
think
i'm trying to figure out like the best
way to
these maybe just
i could temporarily replace them with
another material material perhaps
[Music]
let's do that
where are you all right materials
no still the same
all right let me run you through it so
let's get out of here
all right so we have this beautiful city
in the back
um this is all the kit bash stuff
and it's super cool because it's running
pretty sweet if i select one hit f
i can hop to it let's get that camera
speed all the way up
and i built this uh
i built this like emissive material that
makes it look like there's a bunch of
lights
on these guys
and let me walk you through that first
so if i select this thing
um we can actually find its material
we can scroll down we can control b
that's going to browse us to the actual
asset
let's see
how would i find this thing
where are you material i don't see you
let's do another way let's just go to
the freaking folder all right uh
materials
glass
black alright so this is the instance
let's go to the master material i'll
show you how i set how i set that up
it's pretty simple
um so we navigate to it there boom we
are in the master material
it all comes down to this guy
right here this material
this texture rather
all right so
what i did
uh my good friend marcus he graduated on
an aircraft carrier in san diego it was
super cool
uh electrical engineering very talented
on this aircraft carrier um you know
it's docked it's a museum at this point
and there's a bunch of buildings
you know it's san diego so what i did is
i stopped down i grabbed my dslr i
stopped way down
and i snapped a picture basically like
this i brought this into photoshop
i cropped it um
i
you know straightened it out so
everything was square enough square
looking
um
i painted
any areas uh black that didn't really
belong
and i left the color right i saved this
out
and i bring this
into
the master material now everything is
kind of uh
let's see
here here we go
this master material is set up in this
way where we have this material we have
this texture right
and
it is plugged into i you know i threw a
material function on it if you right
click
material function underscore you're
going to get
the tiling function and that's going to
give you
all of the different
scale
pan
and tiling options the rotation this is
the one that comes with the like quixle
materials i believe you might have to
import a qixel material in order to get
this
in your project
in order for you to search for it
that's how i'm actually moving and
adjusting
this material
and that's multiplied with
the actual emissive intensity i'm
technically not using this we can just
delete that if we want and i'm just just
using an emissive intensity
to power that and that's going into
emissive color
and it gives you a really really cool
looking effect here so if i
go to the actual material
and let's just kind of scrunch this down
this is the instance i'm messing with at
this point
so that tiling i mentioned
right we can
scrunch it down we can make it larger
um
was it 0.075
before
i think it was
make it tiny
just depending on where you're viewing
it from you know
0.01
make it huge
[Music]
i think that's where i had it and then
of course we have the intensity so you
can really
go to town on these windows here
but we're viewing it from way back way
back uh in our set
so
i got them dialed into a
to a look that i like and i just kind of
duplicated all these buildings and
scattered them around
in different spots
we got one way out there these guys way
out there
oh i have a fog card thing as well going
this guy it's hard to see
but
you can kind of see that it's adding a
little bit of atmospheric fog to the
city if we go back to
where are you
we go back inside
[Music]
kind of like look out the window here
you can see that card
is doing a little bit it's doing a
little bit to just kind of blend it into
that
background just a touch
very nice
um
surface imperfections i figured this one
out okay so
let's select the glass let's go to the
instance and i'll show you
kind of what i'm working with here so if
we
open up the max
and min roughness and also the intensity
we can kind of see what's going on
and it's a good good way to
view our roughness from this perspective
actually so the intensity i think is
kind of like
the gamma
and just becomes more apparent
and a little bit brighter
the higher we crank this
and the roughness max will obviously
control like how
rough it will be in the end for the
white values
uh i'll show you how i'm setting this up
so if i take this down to like
you know zero of course it'll be nothing
but if i take the min roughness up to
like point two
and the max roughness to point two
then you can see it just adds a global
roughness to it but if you want just a
little bit of surface imperfection
and you can set that to like
point four and you'll get a little
something
but you'll still have the ability to
bring that bass level that minimum
roughness up and i couldn't figure out
how to do this for the longest time
um i was doing it at the beginning of
these streams i was doing it the wrong
way
so
let me show you how
i'm setting that up and it's so simple
um this is the master material here
all right
and
basically what you have
is
let's start from the top all right so
let's not really worry about the glass
settings
i have an opacity plugged in 0.5 into
opacity
um it's this roughness here that we want
to talk about okay metallic and specular
yeah that's happening
but it's this roughness all right so
what we can do is actually just group
all this hit c and call this
roughness
okay i have this texture this is from my
uh surface imperfection pack
this is like smudges on the glass here
we can search for it open this up
this kind of deal yeah
i got a whole video on this feel i want
to know how to make these yourself
um
it's called like
you know handmade handmade materials or
custom surface imperfections or
something like that
um where i'm actually like painting my
hands on
on a whiteboard and smearing it around
is one way to do fingerprints but i
actually recorded this with uh like a
laptop screen and a light setup
specifically
the whole the video goes into it if you
all want to do it yourself um and of
course
you know shameless plug i do sell these
surface imperfections they are on my
gumroad they are also on my patreon
all right so there's a bunch of
different ones you know you can use
whatever you want during intensities
we've got some rain streaks as well and
i think i'm combining that here on the
glass too
so
back to the master material
so i bring in the material itself right
here yeah
and
let's take this step by step in fact i'm
just going to show it let's do it
together
let's do it together right click
material this is just called test
let's get up in here
all right
perfect
let's go ahead and right click specular
promote this a parameter let's promote
metallic to a parameter and let's
promote roughness to a parameter
actually no
we're doing roughness that's what we're
doing okay base color we'll promote that
to a parameter
all right let's make a chrome
sphere
let's make it metallic let's get this
color to white
save it
and the roughness is what is needed to
make it actually chrome here so we'll
take the roughness to zero and that's
gonna that should do the trick
yeah so we got our chrome ball
looking good we got a super chat fiery
lexu
what is up high fives to ya thank you
very much
good stuff thank you for the support
thanks for the shout outs
good times
where's the pizza yo i had that pizza
had that pizza yesterday
you should be asking how's the pizza
it's the best pizza oh my god the best
pizza
okay let's set up this surface
imperfection so i'm gonna bring in that
texture
uh let's do
we'll we'll bring in two different ones
boom and boom sweet let's mess with it
so here's the cool thing
you can actually keep this roughness
right
and do what's called a static parameter
or a switch parameter so we'll we'll we
can toggle surface and perfection on and
off
so let's do a switch
parameter boom
and we'll call this
surface imperfection question mark
you trying to add some surface
imperfections we're going to pipe this
roughness into false
because obviously if we click true then
we're going to go to the surface
imperfection right so
what you can see if we pipe this into
roughness okay
and by default
it's unchecked
right which means it's going to this
roughness if we change this
to one
by the way do you guys know how to
update this on the left here
when i type this because i i feel like
there's a way
to do it live update
preview material
no that should be that should work um
anyway service surface imperfection
this switch parameter is giving us an
error because it obviously needs like
a true
so we would pipe this into
our surface imperfection
now it's giving us all white
ah that's because
full roughness on a chrome ball i guess
is all white is our base color
so we can set that's like point two
right nice little brushed metal okay
um but what if we check the box we say
yeah let's actually boom
let's add the surface imperfection
and we can see we got this nice like
rough smudged material
it looks great right
let's make this a little bigger for you
guys
oh my god everything's exploding
come on now
come yep now
yeah okay
looks beautiful but it's like yeah i
want more control over this this is not
exactly what i want um
you know we can try this rain material
too pretty sweet
pretty sweet all right but let's stick
with the smudges
let's get some more control over this so
here's how i'm doing this basically
um
if we
make a lerp node all right a larp node
is going to go between two things
um it's like a mixed node in octane
i'm sure there's a very similar
thing in blender
right so what we can do is we can
actually pipe this
material or this texture into the alpha
and that's going to control
the difference between a and b
you know a good example of it would be
you know something like uh if i hold
three
and i promote this to a parameter right
this is a color and we'll pipe uh
is this gonna work actually can i just
go red into a and green into b
and then pipe this into true
and i guess maybe we would have to go
give it some color or something some
value of some sort
okay so it's still
all right this color example
is not what i'm going technically it
would have to go into base color
i think for this example to where can i
have the pull roughness whatever you
guys get the point let me just kind of
revert what i just did there
let's get rid of that
all right and let's make some
parameters here
minimum roughness and
get and max roughness i'm holding s and
left clicking
and i always get mixed up on which one
is which but i think max is a and min is
b
let's set the
max slider to one on these
and the max roughness should be one
all right so it's the other way around
it goes into b i guess and that goes
into
a
and that is going to yield the same
thing as if we just took this
texture and put it into
this the switch parameter
and for what it's worth to keep things
simple let's just go right into
roughness
don't worry about this for now
in fact
we can get rid of that i just want to
keep it very simple for you guys we're
just focused on this roughness
so now with this um
piped in what we can do is we can take
the minimum roughness up to say like
0.2
0.1 or 0.05
0.1 is cool and we can take the max
roughness and we can
take it down to 0.5 so we have a lot
more control
over our surface imperfections
nice and subtle super subtle right
0.5 but what if we want to like
see more of the actual material so what
we can do is take this
we can go to a multiply
and we'll do uh
roughness intensity
i wonder if gamma is also
a word we can use so zero is obviously
zero
one will look exactly the same
but if we take this to two
we're gonna see a lot more of those
streaks like you see if i take it to one
we're not really seeing too much here
but if i take it to two
we're gonna get a lot more of that
texture coming out and we can take that
min roughness to like 0.05
beautiful
and let's switch the texture out
this is all happening from the lerp
the lerp node is allowing us to have
control over this
we're gonna set that to three and get
more even more
intensity out of that um i'm i'm sure at
some point it will break yeah like
right there
kind of like
inverted itself
very very simple so now with the
with this multiply plugged into true and
the switch parameter plugged into
roughness
we have this default value checked on
i'm going to uncheck it okay
and you can set up a bunch of different
surface imperfections with different
switchers to like toggle between
different ones like you can do smudges
or
rain streaks etc
and if we save this
this default roughness value of should
be zero max is one
we'll save that
and
let's go ahead and actually
group all of this into its own
group i'm going to grab all of these
parameters
and we'll find the group and we'll just
call this
roughness
this switch imperfection can also be put
into that same group
we'll save it we'll close it
and
if we apply that to
say know this guy here
or even the window
so we don't want to ever apply the
master material we want to apply
a uh
an instance
shoot i lost my texture
there it is
all right so if i apply the master
material
it's it's going to be rough we're going
to have to go in here we're going to
have to
change our values from here and then
we're going to make a bunch of new
master materials which is going to
duplicate all of these textures which
just box down your system
so the way to do it is you right click
and you just make a material instance
and you apply the instance to the things
you're trying to work with right
so let's see if this is even the best
example of
a place to view it yeah maybe here
let's see let's double click that
okay
so now
if we drop this uh okay so surface
imperfection you can see
um we have a roughness we can crank our
roughness to 0.2
all right we get some roughness out of
that okay great
but what if we want the surface
imperfection so we'll check that we'll
check the surface imperfection box
which then pops the surface imperfection
onto
our chrome material
and then we can adjust these values so
the roughness intensity let's take that
back to one
we can take our max roughness up to one
our minimum roughness to zero
or 0.02 maybe
0.03
and we can bring our max roughness up
just a little bit
all right i meant our intensity boom
there bring the max roughness down to
like .2
and that's a great way to get some uh
really nice control
over your surface imperfections it's a
lot of roughness jeez
broken straight up broken
i'm glad i finally figured that one out
you know because
i love surface imperfections i love
creating
grunge and making stuff feel used and
worn it's such a great way to like make
your stuff look as realistic as possible
so i'm really glad i figured that one
out
um
it's that lerp node finally figuring out
how to use the lerp node it's so simple
it's just a mixed node it's going
between two things using an alpha or
using some sort of value a black and
white value in this case our black and
white value is
the texture
right let's switch it out for that
raindrop material
where are you
i drop material
dang or just another
another imperfection
that looks great
um let's do the raindrops
pipe those in i'll just delete these
save it
all right so let's figure out
some scaling situation remember i
mentioned the material function mf
underscore tiling
yeah just drop one of those here into
your uvs for the image itself we'll save
it
and now if you go into the actual
instance
we have all these tiling options so we
can check this on we can change the
rotation angle
let's go ahead and like
max out that roughness
so we can get a better idea of like
where the streak direction is going
and it looks like it needs to be rotated
90 degrees so that rotation angle we can
take
to 0.25
yeah so the streaks are going down that
way they're also huge
so we can tile it twice
my math is correct maybe four times
all right so we get those nice rain
streaks on here
and then of course we bring it down
because it's
really intense all this flickering and
stuff you're seeing this is like
ray trace reflections
and not having enough samples if i were
to crank the samples it would uh
not be good for my computer right now i
would have to do that on render only
yeah so that's how i'm getting this like
really subtle
uh
surface imperfection here these windows
looks great though shoot
fantastic uh anything else
so
goodness gracious truly is the matrix
um
how are you guys feeling let me let me
ask y'all how are you guys doing in the
chat i've been rambling on for
an hour or so
you guys doing right is there anything
that you want to know any questions that
you may might have uh any specific
unreal engine questions or anything
happy to answer some questions for y'all
it's been fun creating this piece of art
i love spending time
longer than a week creating something
but man it has been crazy especially
with the streams too
it's a lot of work
a lot of work
i'm excited to wrap this out and go on a
little
little mograph vacation
uh meme guy why am i using unreal versus
c4d you know i use both
i use both
um i think unreal is very powerful i
wanted to learn it and uh kind of dive
in
here
because i know it's the future it's so
powerful to be able to get a real-time
view from what you're seeing your head
to on the screen as quick as possible
that's always my goal so
yeah that's why i'm trying to learn it
uh how do i deal with the blotchy
shadows and reflections okay yeah so
basically what i'm doing here is
i mean we can we can go back to that
example
and we'll grab that test
let's see we're getting a lot of noise
in there so if we bring up our post
process volume
and i go to ray i know i'm using
raytraced reflections here
in fact i will
just drop down
reflections i'm using standard raytraced
if we switch to lumen it's going to look
like that
if we and that's by default if you set
it up with lumen all right but if you
switch to raytraced it's going to be
looking real nice
but here's the thing is like
you got all this uh
you know wishy-washy noise in here so if
you go to raytrace reflections
you'll be real careful with this oh also
hold on
screen space
eh
nothing beats that raytraced alright so
max
what i understand is like
if it's set to zero it's basically off
and it's gonna go the fastest
but if you if it's set to one it's gonna
go the slowest and i think it's
basically like a threshold of what will
get those
nice ray trace reflections
so i can set this to like point
two and it's gonna start getting better
like
it's gonna start noticing
some better reflections point four point
0.5 you know i don't know if you need to
go beyond 0.5
because 1 just
that's rough
and default is 0.6 now bounces right
this is great so zero bounces
um i guess we get one
we get one look at what's on the other
side of the mirror
if you do
[Music]
zero is the same as one okay if you go
two it's going to reflect reflections so
it's going to reflect this reflection
on the ground
that's what two is going to give you
right and in the max bounces if we go
three
i don't see why three would be necessary
in this point
but you can start seeing reflections of
reflections of reflections
and the higher this number is the
crazier it gets but we can see between
one and two is our biggest
between two and three
doesn't really get as much so i can keep
that at two
and then the samples per pixel that's
really where
it starts to go down
lord vega i hope you're paying attention
here because
this might this might blow my computer
up this one's for you all right so zero
uh one sample per pixel is gonna give us
that look if we multiply it by four it's
gonna get a little bit nicer let's go
eight it's gonna get a little bit
cleaner it's actually not bad uh we can
go 16
in this certain situation i think we've
maxed it out we don't need to go any
higher than this so i think eight
is fantastic four
it's a little wishy-washy
it seems like eight is doing the job i'm
getting some like
real small
it's so hard to see it looks pretty darn
clean
we can take that eight to a 16 but
i don't know how much that's gonna do
for us
so in this case
you know this is great actually this
test is fantastic because i had this
cranked up to 64.
it was a lot
um now it might be a different story
when it comes to this situation because
this
it
oh no
this is a whole different story
and
my computer is chugging let's turn off
samples per pixel let's turn off bounces
let's turn off roughness okay so now
we're moving okay
we can fly through this
it's a good time all right but as soon
as we like
start cranking these settings let's
let's go to town all right
max roughness
i checked that on
all right our frame rate is not bad
let's actually bring up our fps
okay
scalability let's go to epic
let's go to cinematic bring on the pain
all right
frame rate has dropped
considerably we're at 12 fps 13 fps all
right
okay
so max roughness let's take that to zero
you know it doesn't look bad we go point
one
point two
point three
point four
point five
point six uh
it's not giving us much i think point
five is that sweet spot now bounces max
bounces let's set that to zero
or one two
isn't really doing much for us in this
case
barely we got some on the on the left
corner just above my head
just a little bit
but if we take it to three
again we're not really getting anything
beyond two so there's no reason to
really crank that we can go to five
but that's just not necessary
two is fantastic
samples per pixel all right this is
where it starts to get crunchy um
let's take this to zero
or one we're at 12 fps if i take that to
four
we're down not to nine fps if we go back
to 8
we're hitting 7 fps 16
is going to clean up more of that noise
we're at 4 fps now
um
oof
you know maybe i switch out this
material maybe this doesn't need to be
this chrome
like this it's really intense
um we can take samples per pixel 232
i'll see when the stream crashes
oh boy
i don't even want to move the camera
i'll keep that at eight and i'm gonna
uncheck all this stuff so that's how i'm
doing that um
you know raytrace shadows
you can probably i'm not getting too
much here in my shadows
see these little flickering lights here
i think this could probably just
be these samples
and it cleans it up for sure
so you don't have to actually do that
to have it in your render that's why i
use console commands
let's see if i look for my sequence
we open up the movie render queue this
is a plug-in you have to enable so you
go to plugins look for
movie
render
check these on right
restart and then you'll get the movie
render queue you can hit this little
clapboard
these dot dot dots it'll show you how
you can choose movie render queue open
it up
and
hit the settings here
and if you hit settings
you can add a console variable and these
console variables you can essentially
tell
unreal to render at full blast
so you're going to add one you'll just
add a bunch
right so you can do like r dot
uh
ray traced
dot reflections i'm just making this up
i'll just load the preset i got some
presets here we'll do console variables
rtx
and we can see here ray trace reflection
shadows
all right that's set to two we have ray
traced reflection
sample per pixel set to 64. i don't
think that needs to be 64. like we can
probably just do 16.
raytrace shadow samples per pixel um
that's for the shadows we can probably
just do 16.
so you can plug that stuff in
and render it that way
as opposed to having your post-process
volume be at max capacity all the time
so that's how i'm doing that
very long answer to your question lord
vega
but it's a good question
um who else do we got
i'm making my way down this list here
papaxo i'm looking at the at punitures
uh where's the penguin well the penguin
is
right here
it's our boy
that is our boy but look at that in the
reflection too
oh wait because the post process volume
isn't on you're not seeing it there it
is yeah
reflections on reflections
all right what else do we got questions
questions
one aspiring artist uh what specs do i
recommend for vx vfx computer the best
specs you can't get good enough specs
you have to constantly be going for the
highest specs you can afford
um that's just the truth of it you know
like
that's just the case man um
go for the best you can buy
i think different programs have
different uh
minimum requirements
that are listed on their website so like
blender has their minimum requirements
for blender in terms of uh
vram ram
uh
et cetera right there's a bunch of
different stuff that goes into it but
vram is a thing
ram is a thing uh your processor is
definitely a thing too
and max on on their website they have
recommended minimum requirements unreal
has the same
you can just do a quick quick google
search and kind of see what you're
looking at and that's going to be
minimum you want max you want the most
you can get
right
it is an expensive hobby
but hopefully we can turn them hobbies
into some careers that's why we're here
honestly
every saturday um
we're trying to turn our hobbies into
careers
so i appreciate you all joining me here
on the stream you are helping me do that
um
you know all my patrons all my viewers
here who come here
uh
you know you guys clicking the ads in
the in the links and all that stuff in
the descriptions like all that stuff is
is helping me do that so i can't thank
y'all enough
um
it's freaking sweet
it's great i love that i can do this
uh and give back try and give back of
course you know tutorials baby it's all
about them tutorials
trying to inspire inspire y'all to do
stuff um all right
q a time still going
how much time did it take to render
um this little da vinci
situation this took
i think this took two hours
but you're gonna see a lot of flickering
you're gonna see a lot of the stuff i'm
gonna have to up the resolution to get
in there and like really clean up that
kind of stuff
so i'm trying to render a 4k
we'll see if the computer can handle it
but i'm going to be doing that literally
like right after the stream i'm going to
set up a 4k
export
see if i can get going but uh
this is 32 ray traced reflection samples
at 1080p
took about two hours to get all this
exr sequence
let us see
any more questions ah
random
other than william foshe who would you
recommend to learn davinci resolve
shoot son uh well
william foshee doesn't really teach
resolve too much
he's done a couple videos on it um
[Music]
there is
let's see
for specifically vfx
you have
dang it what's his name from latvia
uh
soto i know
yes andre andre lebron
um he is a great resource for
c4d
for octane
or da vinci
so if y'all are trying to level up
andre lebron is the man
so cool such a good dude
um so check him out andre librov
um
another good resource for davinci to be
honest with you i'm not really watching
davinci tutorials so i don't know
i don't know i'm sorry i wish i could
help you a little bit more but i just
don't know
i'll just look up a quick little thing
how to do this
i'll see the thing all right done you
know um
i'm not as deep into the davinci
tutorial life i've been using it for
long enough that i know basically how to
do what i'm trying to do
but
i am learning fusion or actually that is
a lie
i am
planning to learn fusion
um it is on my list fusion is da vinci's
built-in after effects
uh this is it right here and it is very
powerful
um
you know the more i could is this
particles dude they got emitters my
goodness
my goodness
davinci's crazy actually let me
let me undo that i don't want particles
flying around um
what else do we got what else do we got
logan
when did i start using unreal dude you
can go
back on the channel and find the exact
the exact
video where i started using unreal
uh it was a live stream an early on live
stream i opened it
maybe for the second time maybe i opened
it once or twice off camera
um but
i figured out how to enable ray tracing
on camera and like
it was crazy my mind was blown
but it took me i don't know
i've been using unreal at this point now
for probably two years
and it took me a good while to figure
out how to really grasp it
and it what it really took was a
a project for me to
to knock out and to complete
this is probably my
fifth project in unreal
uh the first project i set out to do was
to create an atmosphere a very simple
atmospheric environment
it's actually one of my latest it's like
six streams ago
and it's of like a little marsh with a
little totem a metal little structure
dead center and i create it live on the
stream
uh with you guys that was what i wanted
to do first
and i didn't have the ability to do that
so
what it what it really took was me uh
finding someone who knew the
program and of course watching tutorials
right i'll just watch tutorial tutorial
but i would have all these questions
that these tutorials didn't hit and
there's better tutorials now and that's
why i make the unreal tutorials that i
do make
is for people like me who just didn't
have those answers to the questions they
had
um but
it took uh
someone reaching out here on the streams
being like hey like i see you struggling
i'd love to help you and that was steve
begin
you know he's my unreal sensei i always
call him sensei steve he pops into the
chat from time to time
and he took
every friday every friday morning out of
his schedule
to answer any questions i had i was like
hey how do i do this how to do that and
he would just give me a few hours of his
time and i'm i'm so indebted to him for
doing that because he
he boosted me up to the point where like
i could start messing around and like
start getting stuff
to
look or go at least in the direction
that i saw in my head
and if it weren't for steve
i wouldn't be as in deep to unreal
engine
and then the first person to really like
start putting out the tutorials
the cinematic tutorials that i was
looking for was of course william poche
he's the man so like i was just
consuming his tutorials
and really diving deep with him
i got to meet him as a friend now and
like you know
um you know we're not like
calling each other up every day like
how's it going but
you know we've talked a little bit and
he's been a guest on
the channel
uh he's been a judge for these
challenges in the past
um and he's been a super solid really
really nice guy and i'm so glad that
i've been able to go a little bit deeper
with him
um
but his tutorials are you know
the best
so with all that i was able to build up
my knowledge of unreal and create my own
tutorials
um tutorials that i
would love to have
and i of course am not a master i don't
know at all so i like to shout people
out and kind of point to people who
helped me get there
steve began and william foshea being two
of them another big one is uh is winbush
he he has a tutorial for everything my
goodness that guy
he's always there like getting you that
very specific tutorial that you need for
that specific problem so windbush has
been a massive uh a massive help for me
and unreal as well and also another
friend
um
uh he's been here i think he's joined us
here on the live streams once he's come
over we've done some photo scans
together he lives close by so
windbush is a good one and i will be in
chicago at half res with windbush where
we're going to be speaking so
definitely come join us if you're in the
chicago area
that's how i learned unreal you know
other than other than that it's just
like getting projects done completing
projects forcing yourself to complete a
project and that's why that's why um
you know these challenges are are so
great
is it gives us a chance to tackle
something it's just an excuse to to
complete a project
and you know we do weekly challenges on
the discord server as well
so
that's a good question how long did it
take me to learn unreal it's a long
answer these are long answers y'all
um
that wasn't even the question it was
when did i when did i start using it
[Music]
good question logan thank you
lord vega gotcha if you guys have any
more questions please
drop them for me let's see i'm going
down the list at the app punishers i'm
just looking at the app punishers
because they're a little bit easier to
see
do i ever game on my vfx computer you
know the reason i use pc is because i am
a gamer
so
all the games were on pc my dad was it
was a gamer
um i'd say he still is a gamer he plays
a lot of magic the gathering these days
magic online
but um
you know we started with with a with a
gaming pc my dad built computers when he
was my age and you know we had an
alienware
when i was growing up and we'd play doom
and
uh
you know uh what other games and so many
so many games so many pc games i was a
playstation kid too so
we always had a playstation in the house
um
what else what else
but recently you know like i think
gaming and vfx goes hand in hand because
you need a nice graphics card to
to run those nicer games
as you need a nice graphics card to run
uh you know do some really nice
intense computing so
i don't play games on my computer too
much anymore i like because i'm on my
computer for work i want to be away from
my computer as much as possible when i'm
not working so that's why i got the
playstation hooked up i got the switch
hooked up
um recently have been loving stray i
beat it three times already got that
platinum trophy
did everything you can do just about
besides glitching through walls which i
did once
and about everything you do in that game
um
what else what am i what am i playing
right now uh
working on horizon zero dawn trying to
get into that game
it's a lot it's a big old open world
thing
i still gotta beat elden ring goddamn
all right back to it more questions
ollie how close would you say to being
done am i with this render
dude i'm never done i'll tell you that
much i'm never done like
this right here
i could tweak this forever man i have to
just abandon it okay i just have to
release it
i have to force myself to be done
i have to be done tomorrow
because that's the deadline right so
i'm done when the deadline is there uh
where where is it at
in my head with like what i'm imagining
i'd say it's pretty close man i'd say
it's like
90 95 90
there's a couple things that i really
want to do namely
populate this with a bit more decals a
bit more trash a bit more detail like on
the floor and stuff maybe i'll have time
to do a pass like that
some cobwebs up here would be great um
something maybe on the left and right it
feels a little empty here
i think that could be helpful something
in the corner i just don't know what i
could just spend more time on this thing
sit with it come up with ideas add
little things here and there little
details i could spend a whole month
doing that you know
um the the next biggest thing that i
need to work on is the actual like
animated layout of this video background
um
you see how it's just static here all
the way up until this point where it
starts moving
right
i would love to have something
here
that is moving a little bit so i'm
probably gonna do a little bit of after
effects work tomorrow
um
to get some movement there
that's pretty much it man like other
than that and like just kind of cleaning
up some noise here we can see it's a
little noisy up at the top
that's just
more samples
bigger
resolution um
that's about it you know it'd be nice to
have some mountains on the right side
over here but it is what it is
it is what it is got to move on at some
point so
yeah man a good question though it's
good question
all right back at it q's and a's
all right what do we got
that's about it huh
that's about it
because i have any more questions i'm
i'm down to answer um i might wrap it up
early here today
um get some lunch
it's about that time
all right
what do i think is the most important
aspect of post processing
i usually just render my stuff in
blender
uh and it's so lost in the after part
okay you're lost in the post-processing
part
all right that's a good question
what's the most important part of
post-processing i would say
you know you can do color correction
inside of uh
of blender you can do color correction
inside of unreal engine inside of c4d
etc so let's just assume that you got
your look and your color in engine okay
from there the most important part i
would say would be like imperfections
subtle imperfections
so
doing just like a little bit of blur to
your image like
one percent blur
so it's not tack sharp and perfect
um and adding grain
is huge
um bloom you can do in engine but
basically like all the things i'm doing
in post you saw here on the stream i'm
color correcting i'm doing all my color
in davinci because i have the most
control in davinci
um i'm adding vin stuff like lens it's a
bunch of like lens
imperfections so vignette
um we have like uh
the barrel distortion which gives you
that fisheye look
that's something i'm adding um film
grain is something i'm adding because
no real footage is perfectly denoised
unless you're shooting like you know
super digital perfectly lit uh de-noised
everything has a little bit of noise and
i'm a big fan of films so
adding that film green and the film
imperfections back in
is something that i love doing and then
like i said that little one percent of
blur is is very helpful to have because
nothing is if you look at footage and
you zoom in to 100
it's not gonna be a perfect straight
line it's gonna have a little bit of
blur to it um
bloom is another great thing these are
lens effects that
emulate
real cameras so i'm just trying to
emulate a real camera as much as
possible
oh thank you
amazing
wonderful wife
nice little tumeric ginger blast
cayenne spiciness
yes
these things are the best
um
those are the main things i'm doing in
post
uh i could go a little bit further and
like mask some stuff out i i could just
add a bunch of uh like render out a z
depth pass
and add a bunch of like atmospheric
clouds and fog and all this stuff not
really necessary in this render but
something that you can definitely do
um
all right let me get this get to these
last questions here
oh we got a whole nother batch
frank what's up frank hey uh first time
catching the stream you want to say
thanks
uh your project appeared in the led cube
in seagraph
i feel like oh yeah big thank you for
all the things you've taught me dude
that's awesome
freaking c-graph led cube that's great
absolutely man thanks for stopping by
i'm glad you uh
have learned a lot and i'm glad that
you're joining the stream for the first
time that's cool man
[Music]
when will the top 100 video drop that's
a great question probably all of you are
wondering the same so next saturday is
the uh judges the judgment day
stream where we're gonna react to the
top 100 and announce the top five
artists that's next saturday don't miss
it add it to your calendar if you're on
the discord server it's an event it's
already there
um
the week after so two weeks from today
is when the top 100 comes out
so excited so so excited uh my buddy
adam who goes by feverkin he's doing the
music for it it's gonna be incredible
what am i looking for when i judge uh
that's another good question so i'm
looking for
first i i've explained this before but
i'm gonna lay out every single render in
the timeline in davinci
and i'm gonna go through
and i'm gonna watch them all and if one
of them
looks like it's rendered really nicely
it goes up
and then
i will try and pick the top 125 based
off of that
it's like how well does it look
is your lighting solid
are your color solid
is your color correction solid like your
tones
your saturation is your atmosphere like
how's your atmosphere it's like a
general vibe i'm just like
is it looking great from that first
glance then it goes up right
so i try and pull the top 125
and from there i whittle it down
uh to the top 100
based off of a really like detailed pass
looking at everything ask myself like
why does this one look better than this
one does the simulation on this one look
kind of janky
etc so we'll kind of whittle it down
and that's kind of when it all comes
into account here like looking at story
looking at lighting looking at
composition
uh looking at render quality
of course did you follow the rules
um and then it gets into
like when it when it starts to whittle
down even further i'd like to pick the
top 20 that myself and the judges
uh determine as the top five
and that will just be you know the best
the best on all those categories that i
just mentioned
um story and uh
uniqueness
starting to really shine and be
important here
um because everyone can do sci-fi robot
like render but it but you're up against
like
a thousand other sci-fi robot renders
is your sci-fi robot render really the
best sci-fi robot render
um you know how many of these have we
seen
but oh maybe you come across like frog
world
and it's like rendered perfectly and
um
you know it's like it's a bit more
unique then i think uniqueness starts to
really shine here in these top five um
and in the top 20.
so then it goes from there and we just
talk about it with the judges go back
and forth we list our top five out
individually
talk about why
and um kind of assign points to
different shots and we figure out our
top five and we sit with it and we're
like are we happy with this does this
make sense do we want to swap anything
for anything
um
you know for gut reasons for
uh quality reasons for
uh you know like this thing just looks
amazing for this reason et cetera et
cetera so it could be like
we do a second pass on it just to make
sure we're 100 positive with our like
analytical
top five and we're like does this feel
right and then you know
that's how that's how it goes
uh visual did i like using dazzy hey it
was pretty sweet actually um visual's
the dazz master yes
it was pretty cool
i liked how easy it was to like slide
between all the different character
morphs and everything
um you can buy characters on their store
that are pretty cheap they're pretty
affordable and you can like crank these
sliders and make them more old or make
them more buff or
you know make their hands all big or
something it was a really really cool
program and it was a great way to add
clothes and import that into c4d or into
unreal so i think i'll be using daz for
sure
again on the character side it's been
something that's been such a difficult
thing for me is doing characters and
having a
workflow for characters now or at least
a glimpse into a possible workflow for
characters now is is great so
i'm happy about that
abdullah yes i will make more unreal
tutorials don't you worry my friend i'm
going to be doing a whole breakdown of
my scene here going into all the cool
stuff
um in a nice 20 25 minute video for
y'all so that'll be a nice little nugget
of info
for you guys when it comes to unreal
engine
all right
paul what's up paul shout out to team
man
uh solid a solid patron yes indeed great
stream
learn load's definitely going to be my
go-to
um
video for for post processing oh heck
yeah
thank you man
absolutely shout outs to you
oh man how did i learn composition jeez
okay uh let me take this
delicious cayenne ginger shot and i
won't answer that question
how did i learn composition
a couple things come to mind
ah
i love that burn
so good
um
honestly i think it came
from
[Music]
uh well there's a book actually hold on
kind of a multi-part
answer
[Music]
i don't know where the book is right now
it's around it's called the visual story
what's the name of the book
um i'm gonna get to that in a second all
right but basically i think the way i
learned composition was through watching
movies and playing video games
for years
i think that was that was it um
and kind of getting a gut instinct for
what i liked and what i didn't like and
i gravitate towards certain images that
are like wow this image is so cool look
following photographers on instagram is
probably a good way to do so now
and um learning through them learning
through professionals
and
watching the best of the best
watching the best movies following the
best artists
um
and really taking in
how they're creating that effect and
asking yourself how are they getting
that like and studying it you know
so uh i brought this up multiple times
shot deck is a great resource you can
look up uh different
well any movie they're all screenshots
from movies so you can look up any movie
you can type interior you can type
exterior you can type uh you know
interior car shot etc right
and
find
certain shots that you like that speak
to you and start to develop a
a library an internal library of things
you like and things you don't like and
that will shape the way your art
is made of course um
but that book the visual story
is like the math and the science of why
things work and why things don't
compositionally so it talks about
everything from color how you can
separate foreground and background with
color
um how you can do that with with uh like
uh tones and values lights and darks
that kind of stuff it talks about shapes
talks about um
i mean that that's my main takeaway from
the book it's a solid book right
uh with a ton of pictures and examples
from movies screenshots and stuff
so that's one there's another
book called master shots this one's
awesome
[Music]
and this one is all about
like
different shots in movies that
make you feel a certain way
if you want people
to let's see
i've talked about this once before on
stream
but all these different chapters right
so you got like fight scenes chase
scenes suspense dramatic uh
you know entrances and exits all
different things that like it's this is
the cinematic language right here this
book and it talks about how to move the
camera
how to
get tension from someone with a camera
move that kind of stuff this one is
great
oh
such a good book so i mean composition
is based around that as well
those are just some things
um that in photography go out take take
photos
it really helps with your composition
uh you study it you practice it back and
forth back and forth
all right
we got questions for days here y'all
switch you missed the whole thing so
it's all good
you watch it back
definitely but with that guys i think
i might have to bounce here um
get some food here
ah get some get some sleep
definitely uh all right so final things
okay final announcements next week
next saturday is judgment day
all right
so come prepared
mentally physically spirit whatever you
got to do all right come prepared next
week we'll be joined by some guest
judges
i will be announcing the judges later in
the week we're going to be getting
together reacting to the top 100 and
announcing the top five winners of this
moving meditations challenge
um this is like if you if you
caught any stream this is the stream to
catch next week okay
so put it in your damn calendar uh
10 45 a.m
pst
right that's 10 45 a.m pacific standard
time
i will see you for judgment day we're
gonna look at the best of the best
joined by the judges uh other than that
we got the top 100 coming out the week
after that
um
the deadline for this thing is tomorrow
11 59 pm
pst 11 59 pm pst as soon as it hits
monday
in california
it's over
for everybody it is over
um so good luck to you all
i know y'all
probably don't need it at this point
maybe some of you do so good luck to
those those of you who do
um
and i will uh
i'll be seeing you guys
i will be seeing you guys thank you so
much for joining me thanks for hanging
out
on the last stream of all the streams
you guys are the real ones
made it all the way to the end thank you
very much
catch y'all soon kit bash codes 50 off
uh should be linked in the description
pinned up in the chat here
um there's only 50 of them so if you're
trying to get some kit-bashed stuff
definitely do that
i'll see you guys next week for judgment
day peace out y'all have a good one
later
[Music]
did
[Music]